I'm LOD and I play a leaf or timotheus
to buy some time but be careful Santora
there is everyone else coming for you
right now digit looks for the damaged
flashes that looks for a rookie deletes
half the light up already
a double coup coming out a lot he knows
about 12 and I was playing well and my
parents didn't want to pay for my
subscription anymore so I was just like
looking for a free game and I baited in
by one that was like clickbait
advertising on the side of a website it
was like free game play now and I was
like yeah sure
so I downloaded it and this was like
right before season 1 when I think cars
and just came out and I just played a
lot of 3v3 I think the first champion
ever played with gangplank and I just
didn't understand why I was killing my
own minions didn't make sense to me but
either way like I don't know something
about the games maybe kind of fall in
love and I just played it a lot I just
kind of looked at all the pro players at
the time like Reggie and hotshot and
stuff and I just kind of like got drawn
in by the lifestyle there living
I guess it wasn't like super glamorous
or anything but some really cool that
they were like pretty young and
traveling the world client like
Dreamhack I am just all these cool
tournaments and just seeing that they
had so many fans and stuff so I kind of
just wanted to go for that
at first my family was super skeptical
like they thought I was getting scammed
or something you know obviously at first
they didn't believe it and they were
just kind of mad at me that I was
playing so many video games because I
was like staying up past my curfew and
stuff to like play more and more so like
you eventually like over time I kind of
showed them that you know it's like a
viable career path and they supported me
after that a lot of my friends don't
really play league back home some do
though the ones that do are like super
happy for you happy for me and they've
like followed to protein so they found
like a full understanding of it the ones
that down are just like oh you play
video games for a living like how does
that work Quadra kill for a lot and c92
push of the base lot every time he's on
this jinx he definitely delivers 100%
killed participation I played it on CIT
for almost a year and it was kind of a
roller coaster right before the most
important match you Sooey had gotten
banned for buying something like 80
accounts we only have three days to find
a sub it was just really weird but then
we kind of got lucky because sticks a
then got banned for being toxic around
the exact same time so it was like four
before we just like ended up winning
that series getting into NACS what we
had an unfortunate start because you
choose so bad for the first week and we
lost our first couple games I believe
even though we were a lot better six
months ago we ended up having a super
disappointing split and what can really
figure things out as a team our roster
just like didn't gel I guess people just
had different mindsets I still felt like
really confident as a player like I was
I never really kind of I never I never
started to doubt myself I'm used to
losing so I kind of picked myself up
right away and started solar Kings like
you know I like my career's not over
here I still want to keep playing and I
want to show people that I'm capable
energy are built entirely around their
substitute ad carry law
honestly the experience is really good
I've been waiting so long to play LCS
and I finally got a chance even if it
was a small one so I was extremely happy
I think it's really really like hard to
fit in as a sub hey or it can be I like
to think of myself as a super vocal
player like I try and talk a lot but
even though I liked all the people I was
subbing for and the organs I was
something for like as a sub especially
as an ad carry I kind of wanted to just
sit back and only just try and do my job
as best I could you know I didn't want
like speak up and make calls or like
like big decisions or like help too much
with Draft because they obviously all
have their own ways of playing so I
found it sort of difficult to really
show like my true potential as a sub and
it was tough I actually only ended up
winning one out of like five games so a
lot of people wrote me off
I got a message from Envy like telling
me about the roster and when I saw it I
was like holy this this is really good
like this is such a good opportunity and
obviously because I was the rookie I'm
unproven like I had to do tryouts and
stuff and you know I was really
confident I was thinking like I'm not
gonna blow this you know I want to like
prove to everybody that I'm like the
best person for the position I just
jumped right into a hockey oh and like I
was super tryharding so lucky usually I
just roll until the queue but I was like
I put my pants on you know like I really
wanted to impress him so we ended up
winning almost every scrim or not scram
so like you when you had like 95% win
rate for like 30 games or something I
feel like I've never actually gelled
with the support before like I've had
many many many over the years I probably
had like 20 20 supports over the past
like five or six years and I've never
really found someone whose playstyle I
actually mesh with and could agree with
you know whether it be like because
someone's like too emotional or like
just not skilled enough you know there's
always been something in the way but
with Nick with hockey oh like I feel
like some reason our place I was
mentally perfectly and we had like a
really good way about figuring out like
what went wrong or what my right having
the top side of that like top jungle in
mid that I can like I feel like I can
always trust them like even if things do
go poorly I feel like like I don't care
you know I kind of accept it and it's
just like you know I trust them fully so
I've never I don't think I've ever felt
like I've had teammates that I could
trust this much you know I want to win
more than anything in the world right I
want I want to prove myself everyone
wants to prove themselves but even if we
do have to lose like so be it you know
like we're just gonna continue you
better never gave up on the play they
get the ACE as CEO G tried to push too
far I want to win world it's like it
should be everybody's goal you know it
is sort of a like a joke in na or
whatever but I want to like at least
make it to Worlds and at least make like
a run at the cop you know